and
action
that's the way give me a second
okay if you thought you couldn't
possibly love adele's new track easy on
me more than you already do
just wait until you see the outtakes
from the music video
absolutely on thursday the singer posted
a two-minute blooper reel to instagram
alongside a cheeky caption quote it's
all smoke and mirrors
and while the music video might have had
you reaching for the tissues
[Music]
the gag reel will have you laughing your
face off
yeah i'm keeping that
forever
sorry yeah
yeah that coke gave her a hard time
[Music]
but it was perfect oh right
and the cassette player wasn't exactly
working for her either she
[Music]
again
[Music]
and while she worked that wind like a
boss
turns out wind machines
aren't all that glamorous
[Music]
of course the grammy winner recently
shared the track list for her highly
anticipated new album 30 which is set to
drop on november 19th in addition to
easy on me the album features a track
called i drink wine and an interlude
titled all night parking it looks really
amazing and while fans have only gotten
a sneak peek at 30 adele will preview a
few more songs from the project during
the upcoming cbs concert special adele
one night only on november 14th she
played three new songs she played some
of her classics she sounds like the
adele that you know and love e.t
recently chatted with gayle king who
attended the taping and she said the
33-year-old singer crushed it i believe
nobody has a voice like hers nobody and
she did not disappoint she just looked
so good
the dress she was wearing made me think
i'm going to give up eating cupcakes
until the next day the special will also
feature a candid conversation with
gail's bestie oprah winfrey and while
the news anchor played coy about the
interview she did tease this
i'll say this i've just heard from
reliable sources it went very very well
you